This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. All families tell stories about themselves. Those stories are passed down and like an intergenerational game of telephone, the details sometimes change from fact to fiction. I was always told that my grandpa sold Elvis his first guitar. My family did live in Memphis at the time. The family business was tuning pianos and selling instruments, so it is possible.
这是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。所有的家族都会讲述关于他们自己的故事。这些故事代代相传，就像一场跨代际的传话游戏，细节有时会从事实变成虚构。我一直听说我爷爷把埃尔维斯的吉他卖给了他。当时我的家族确实住在孟菲斯。家族的生意是调钢琴和卖乐器，所以这是有可能的。
but every member of my family was an unabashed fabulous, so who knows? If you've ever wondered how much of your family lore is actually true, then I have a podcast for you. And what's especially great about it is that one of the people who works on it is from our 99PI family, Katie Mingle. Family lore is a weekly narrative podcast that celebrates and investigates the stories families tell to themselves about themselves. It is really great. Here is an episode of Family Lore. With host, Lloyd Lockridge. You might remember back in 1999, the United States Mint started producing specialty quarters.
但我的家族成员个个都是满口传奇的大嘴巴，所以谁知道呢？如果你也曾怀疑过你的家族传说有多少是真实的话，那么我有一个播客要推荐给你。它特别棒的一点是，其中一位工作人员来自我们99PI的大家庭，凯蒂·明格尔。“家族传说”是一个每周播出的叙事类播客，旨在致敬并调查家族们对自己诉说的故事。它真的很棒。下面是《家族传说》的一期节目。由主持人劳埃德·洛克里奇主持。你可能还记得在1999年，美国铸币局开始生产特种25美分硬币。
On the back of each quarter, instead of an eagle spreading its wings and looking off to the side, you'd see a unique design representing any given state. For example, on the back of the Massachusetts quarter, you'd have a minute man. The Virginia quarter featured ships arriving at Jamestown in 1607. And on the back of the North Carolina quarter, you had a man lying prostrate on a primitive airperson. with another man watching from below. This, of course, was a depiction of the Wright brothers and their inaugural flight at the small beach town of Kitty Hawk.
在每枚硬币的背面，不再是一只展翅翱翔并向一侧张望的老鹰，而是能看到代表各个州的独特设计。例如，在马萨诸塞州硬币的背面，你会看到一个民兵。弗吉尼亚州的硬币则以1607年抵达詹姆斯敦的船只为特色。而在北卡罗来纳州硬币的背面，你会看到一个人俯卧在一架原始飞行器上。另一个人在下方观看。这当然是对莱特兄弟及其在基蒂霍克这个小海滨小镇进行首飞的描绘。
At the top of the coin is the inscription, First Flight. This is a story that virtually all Americans know. The Ride Brothers were the first to fly. The Ride Brothers invented the airplane. Or at the very least, the Ride Brothers were pioneers in the field of aviation. But there's another story you probably haven't heard that makes the origins of American aviation, a little more complex. I'm Lloyd Lockridge, and this is family lore. This story begins in Louisiana, a state not known for aviation, quite the opposite, really. With its bayous, swamps,
硬币顶部刻有“首次飞行”的字样。这是一个几乎所有美国人都知道的故事。莱特兄弟是第一批飞行的人。莱特兄弟发明了飞机。或者至少，莱特兄弟是航空领域的先驱。但还有一个你可能没听过的故事，它让美国航空的起源变得更加复杂一些。我是劳埃德·洛克里奇，这里是“家族传说”。这个故事始于路易斯安那州，一个并不以航空闻名，恰恰相反的州。这里有河口、沼泽、
labyrinthine coastline, and the nation's biggest river, the state is known for its boats, Cajun Pee-Rogues, flat-bottom airboats, paddle steamers, the Higgins boat. But the Louisiana man at the center of this episode's family lore was not interested in boats. He was not interested in navigating the water. Before the advent of airplanes, this man dreamed of navigating the sky. His name was Charles Frederick Page. And to hear his story, we have traveled to Alexandria, Louisiana in person, to speak with one of his descendants, Charles Frederick Page's grandson. So let's just get started. Could you tell me your name, please? Joseph P. Page. Joseph Page is 87 years old. He's a veteran of the United States Air Force and his military background shows.
错综复杂的海岸线和全国最大的河流，这个州以其船只闻名：卡津独木舟、平底风力船、明轮船、希金斯艇。但本集家族传说核心的那位路易斯安那州人对船只并不感兴趣。他对在水上航行不感兴趣。在飞机问世之前，这个人就梦想着在天空中航行。他的名字叫查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇。为了听他的故事，我们亲自来到了路易斯安那州的亚历山大市，采访他的一位后代，查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇的孙子。那么我们就直接开始吧。请问能告诉我您的名字吗？约瑟夫·P·佩奇。约瑟夫·佩奇今年87岁。他是美国空军退伍军人，他的军人背景显露无遗。
His house is tidier than a nuclear submarine. And Mr. Page stands with a certain posture, one that conveys not only physical strength, but a kind of strength of character. He's the kind of person who, without saying a word, makes you want to take your hat off when you walk inside. We were greeted by him and his wife of 65 years. We sat down in his living room and immediately launched into a conversation about his early life. Well, I grew up on Highway 20th East in Pineville, so we lived in a country and about a hundred yards away. Joseph came of age in 1950s, Louisiana, an overtly and unapologetically racist environment. Despite living in Pineville, he had to commute across the Red River to Alexandria in order to
他的房子比核潜艇还要整洁。佩奇先生站姿挺拔，不仅散发着体魄的力量，还流露出一种人格的力量。他是那种无需多言，就会让你在走进门时想要脱帽致意的人。我们受到了他和结婚65年的妻子的迎接。我们在他的客厅坐下，立刻聊起了他早年的生活。嗯，我在派恩维尔东20号公路长大，所以我们住在乡下，大概一百码远的地方。约瑟夫在20世纪50年代的路易斯安那州长大，这是一个公开且毫不掩饰的种族主义环境。尽管住在派恩维尔，他必须乘车穿过红河前往亚历山大，以便
attend the only all-black school in the area. And to add insult to injury, even if he were the first person at the municipal bus stop, he'd have to wait. for all the white passengers to board first, only to pass them all on his way to the back of the bus. And dignities like that were a part of daily life. And this kind of blatant discrimination was a confusing experience for young Joseph Page, because his neighbors out in the country were white, and he'd play with his neighbors all the time. But if they saw each other in the town of Alexandria,
去上当地唯一的全黑人学校。更雪上加霜的是，即便他是市政公交车站的第一个人，他也必须等待。所有白人乘客先上车，结果在上车走向车尾时还要从他们身边经过。这样的羞辱是日常生活的一部分。而这种明目张胆的歧视对年轻的约瑟夫·佩奇来说是一段令人困惑的经历，因为他在乡下的邻居是白人，他总是和邻居们一起玩。但如果在亚历山大镇上看到对方，
they'd have to pretend like they didn't know each other. I didn't quite understand it as a child. In my mind, I knew it was not right. as to why we could be friends and hang out together in the country when nobody was around, but we could not associate with each other when we were in Alexandria. And as a child, you remember thinking this doesn't make any sense? Yeah, I did. Something was wrong.
他们就得假装不认识对方。我小时候并不是很理解。在心里，我知道这是不对的。为什么当四下无人时，我们可以在乡下做朋友一起玩，但到了亚历山大，我们就不能互相交往呢？作为小孩子，你记得自己当时觉得这根本说不通吗？是的，我记得。有些事情不对劲。
I couldn't exactly put my hands on it. But by the time I got to junior high school, I knew for a fact that was wrong. And I recognized it as discrimination. Joseph was grappling with these issues in the midst of a national reckoning. The Civil Rights Act of 1964 was on the horizon, and the movement for racial equality was gaining momentum. But Joseph had no illusions about the reality of his situation. Despite the promises of civil rights, Joseph's parents told him that he'd need to work twice as hard as white people to achieve the same results. And this was not some abstract lesson.
我具体说不上来。但等我上初中时，我确信那是错的。我意识到这是歧视。约瑟夫正处于国家清算的漩涡中，苦苦挣扎于这些问题。1964年《民权法案》即将来临，争取种族平等的运动正在积聚势头。但约瑟夫对自己的现实处境没有任何幻想。尽管民权法案作出了承诺，约瑟夫的父母还是告诉他，他需要付出比白人多两倍的努力才能取得同样的成果。这并不是什么抽象的教训。
It was inextricably connected to the story of the family's patriarch, Joseph's grandfather, Charles Ford. Frederick Page. Charles Page was born in 1864 in Rapides Parish, Louisiana. He was born into slavery, which means that Joseph Page's grandfather, not his great-great-grandfather or some distant relative, but his grandfather was at one point enslaved. I should have told my grandchildren now to underscore the point of slavery was not that long ago. Think about that. So tell me one of the first things you remember learning about your grandfather Charles Frederick Page? Well, my parents and my aunt and uncles, always talked about it. When I was a small kid, he was a bigger-than-life figure in my mind as a kid.
它与家族大家长——约瑟夫的祖父查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇的故事有着千丝万缕的联系。查尔斯·佩奇于1864年出生于路易斯安那州拉皮德斯帕里什。他出生时即为奴隶，这意味着约瑟夫·佩奇的祖父，不是他的曾祖父也不是什么远房亲戚，而是他的祖父曾一度沦为奴隶。我现在应该告诉我的孙子们，强调一下奴隶制其实并没有那么久远。想想看。那么，请告诉我你关于祖父查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇最早的记忆之一是什么？嗯，我的父母、姑姑和叔叔们，总是谈论他。当我还是个小孩子的时候，在我心里，他是一个超越常人的伟岸人物。
They always told us about inventing in the first airship. In case he didn't catch that, Joseph said that he was always told that his grandfather invented the first airship. And we would go, as school kids would do, we would go to school in elementary school and say, my grandfather built the first airship. And the other kids would laugh at us and say, you know that's not right. The Wright brothers built the first airplane. So as a kid, you don't want to be embarrassed by your friends, right?
他们总是告诉我们关于他发明第一艘飞艇的事。如果你没听清的话，约瑟夫是说他从小就被告知他的祖父发明了第一艘飞艇。我们就会像学校的小孩一样，上小学时去学校说，我爷爷造了第一艘飞艇。然后别的孩子会嘲笑我们，说，你知道那不对。莱特兄弟造了第一飞机。所以作为孩子，你不想被朋友们嘲笑，对吧？
So you stop talking about it. This claimed that Charles Frederick Page invented an airship prior to the Wright brothers inventing the airplane. This was a strong piece of Page family lore. It's something the family believes to be true. But a lot of people outside the family are skeptical at best. Those who knew Charles Page respected him, but for other reasons. He was a Renaissance man. He was a timberman, a cobbler, a botanical farmer.
所以你就再也不谈论它了。这种声称查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇在莱特兄弟发明飞机之前就发明了飞艇的说法。这是佩奇家族传说中强有力的一部分。这是家族深信不疑的事情。但家族之外的许多人顶多也就是持怀疑态度。认识查尔斯·佩奇的人都很尊敬他，但原因别有他物。他是个文艺复兴式的全才。他是个伐木工、鞋匠、植物种植者。
He established a cemetery for the black community in Pineville, the first of its kind, the Lincoln Cemetery. He had a vision for diversified farming, where a tenant farmer could slowly gain equity in the land he was working. But what a lot of his peers didn't know is that he also had a mind for injurcified. He would have been a great engineer. Well, my grandmother used to complain about when she would tell my grandfather, she needed to do chicken coop. You need to build her a new chicken coop. He would get out the ruler and a pencil and paper and he would design it and
他在派恩维尔为黑人社区建立了一个墓地，这是同类中的第一个，即林肯公墓。他对手工农业有远见，认为佃农可以慢慢获得他所耕种土地的产权。但他的许多同龄人不知道的是，他也有工程头脑。他本可以成为一个伟大的工程师。嗯，我奶奶过去常常抱怨，当她告诉爷爷，她需要做鸡舍时。你需要给她建一个新的鸡舍。他会拿出尺子、铅笔和纸来设计它，
he would do all this stuff. All I need is a simple chicken coop. It doesn't not have to be like perfect, you know. But Charles Page had bigger ambitions than state-of-the-art chicken coops. In one evening, while sitting on his porch, he got an idea from an unlikely contributor, the mosquito hawk, those big, gangly, slow-moving mosquito-looking insects that you tend to see in the spring and fall. The story I heard repeatedly was that he would sit on his porch in the evenings and watch the flight of those mosquito hawks.
他会做所有这些事情。我只需要一个简单的鸡舍。它不需要十全十美，你知道的。但查尔斯·佩奇的野心远不止最先进的鸡舍。一天傍晚，当他坐在门廊上时，他从一个意想不到的贡献者那里得到了灵感——蚊鹰，也就是那些你在春秋两季经常看到的又大、又瘦长、行动缓慢、长得像蚊子的昆虫。我反复听到的故事是，他傍晚会坐在门廊上观察那些蚊鹰的飞行，
and that inspired him to figure out how he could duplicate that and fly himself and figure out how to do that. And in the ensuing weeks, months, or even years, nobody knows for sure. Charles Page worked on a way to fly. And he had a deadline. He needed to design and build something in time for the 1904 Louisiana Purchase Exposition, which was held in St. Louis, Missouri. You might not have heard of this event before,
这启发了他去找出如何复制这种飞行，让自己也能飞起来，并弄清楚如何做到这一点。在随后的几周、几个月甚至几年里，谁也说不准。查尔斯·佩奇致力于寻找飞翔的方法。他有一个死线。他需要设计并建造一样东西，好赶上1904年在密苏里州圣路易斯举办的路易斯安那购地博览会。你以前可能没听说过这个活动，
but it was a huge deal. The exposition lasted seven months. It dominated the newspapers. It doubled as the location of the 1904 Olympics. It saw 19 million visitors who feasted their eyes on the most cutting-edge inventions from around the world. And there were competitions for various categories.
但这是一件大事。博览会持续了七个月。它占据了各大报纸的头条。它同时也是1904年奥运会的举办地。它迎来了1900万游客，让他们饱览了来自世界各地的最尖端发明。各个类别都有相应的比赛。
For example, the person with the greatest achievement in aviation would walk away with a $100,000 prize, about $3.5 million in today's money. Well, the Page family has always maintained that prior to the Louisiana Purchase exposition of 1904, Charles completed designs of his airship. But that's not all. They say he also used his self-taught construction and engineering skills to build a workable, full-size airship. The Page family doesn't know how long it took Charles Page to build the ship, or how exactly he procured all the necessary materials. But according to the family,
例如，在航空领域取得最伟大成就的人将带走10万美元的奖金，相当于今天的约350万美元。嗯，佩奇家族一直坚称，在1904年路易斯安那购地博览会之前，查尔斯完成了他飞艇的设计。但不仅如此。他们说他还利用自己自学的建筑和工程技能，建造了一艘可用的、全尺寸的飞艇。佩奇家族不知道查尔斯·佩奇花多长时间建造了这艘飞船，也不知道他是如何确切采购到所有必需材料的。但据家族所说，
the vessel was built. And after it was built, Charles Page signed up for the Louisiana Purchase. his exposition and made arrangements to transport the ship. In those days, the fastest way of getting something that big to a city 600 miles away was to put it on a freight train. Obviously, he could not ride on a freight train with the ship. So he had it put on the train thinking that it would arrive in St. Louis, and at some point he would arrive there. But after parting ways with his airship, he got word that it never arrived in St. Louis. He received no explanation. All he was told, is that his invention was not received at its destination. Why didn't it arrive in St. Louis? What happened to?
这艘飞船被建造出来了。建造完成后，查尔斯·佩奇报名参加了路易斯安那购地博览会，并安排了飞船的运输。在那个年代，把这么大的东西运到600英里外的城市最快的方法就是把它装上货运列车。显然，他不可能和飞船一起坐货运列车。所以他把它装上火车，想着它会到达圣路易斯，而他也会在某个时候到达那里。但在与他的飞船分开后，他接到消息说它从未到达圣路易斯。他没有收到任何解释。他被告知的全部就是，他的发明没有在目的地收到。为什么它没有到达圣路易斯？它发生了什么？
And, of course, speculation says it was lost. How can you lose something that big? I mean, it's not like a matchbox. You know, this is a full-scale model that he built to put on that train. So how do you lose something that big? You can only speculate that he was stolen or destroyed, or it was taken by somebody and examined for its mechanical or engineering configurations. Whether the ship was stolen, destroyed, or somehow spontaneously flew off into the sunset on its own,
当然，猜测说它丢了。你怎么能把那么大的东西弄丢呢？我的意思是，它不像火柴盒。你知道，这是他建好用来装上那列火车的全尺寸模型。所以你怎么能弄丢这么大的东西呢？人们只能推测它是被偷了、被毁了，或者是被某人拿去检查其机械或工程结构了。无论这艘飞船是被偷了、被毁了，还是不知怎么地自己突然飞向了日落，
the invention was never seen again. And, according to his descendants, Charles Page never built another one. We're not sure why. Perhaps he wanted to, but couldn't dedicate the time and resources while trying to support 11 kids. Invening the airplane was a side gig. His main focus to take care of his family, he was a timberman and a farmer. He was a good enough timberman to look at a tree
这项发明就再也没有出现过。而且据他的后代说，查尔斯·佩奇再也没有建造过第二艘。我们不确定原因。也许他想，但在试图养活11个孩子的同时，无法投入时间和资源。发明飞机只是个副业。他的主要重点是照顾家人，他是一个伐木工和农民。他是一个足够优秀的伐木工，看一眼树就能
and determine how many feet of lumber he would get out of that tree. In addition to being a timberman, Page was remembered by his friends and family as a community leader. In 1911, there were threats of race riots when a black man murdered a white man in Pineville. Charles Page helped lead a meeting to unite the community, expressing deep regret for the death of the victim, condemning all violence, and pledging to bring the guilty party to justice. And thanks to Charles Page, cooler heads prevailed. His daughter Eva once said in an interview, he always thought people were more important than airships. Charles Page passed away in 1937 at 73 years old. his obituary describes him as a deep thinker who had many visions which he attempted to put into execution.
确定能从那棵树上砍下多少英尺的木材。除了是一名伐木工，佩奇还被他的朋友和家人铭记为社区领袖。1911年，当一名黑人在派恩维尔谋杀了一名白人时，曾有发生种族骚乱的威胁。查尔斯·佩奇协助主持了一场旨在团结社区的会议，对受害者的死亡表示深切哀悼，谴责一切暴力行为，并承诺将有罪者绳之以法。多亏了查尔斯·佩奇，冷静的理智占了上风。他的女儿伊娃曾在一次采访中说，他总是认为人比飞艇更重要。查尔斯·佩奇于1937年去世，享年73岁。他的讣告将他描述为一位深思熟虑的思想家，有着许多试图付诸实践的远见。
But the extent of those visions was known to very few outside the Page family in the black community in Alexandria and Pineville. By and large, his contributions to aviation were not recognized, and many who were aware of the story simply didn't believe it. Over the years, Joseph Page and his family have tried to raise awareness, but at some point, if people don't believe you and you don't have much in the way of hard proof, roof, what more can you do? Well, there in Alexandria, just a few miles away from Joseph's home, was a local history buff who specialized in setting the record straight. And this guy had just stumbled upon an old forgotten article about someone he'd never heard of. So I looked at this story. It starts talking about him exhibiting at the Louisiana Purchase World's Fair in St. Louis or attempting to and patenting an airplane. I said, oh my God.
但这些宏愿的程度，除了佩奇家族以及亚历山大和派恩维尔的黑人社区外，鲜为人知。总的来说，他对航空事业的贡献没有得到认可，许多知道这个故事的人根本不相信它。多年来，约瑟夫·佩奇和他的家人一直试图提高人们的意识，但在某种程度上，如果人们不相信你，而你又没有什么确凿的证据，你能做些什么呢？嗯，就在亚历山大，离约瑟夫家只有几英里远的地方，有一位当地的历史爱好者，专门负责澄清事实。而这家伙刚好偶然发现了一篇关于一个他从未听说过的人的被遗忘的旧文章。所以我看了这个故事。它开始谈论他在圣路易斯的路易斯安那购地世界博览会上参展，或者试图参展，并为一架飞机申请专利。我说，哦，天哪。
Easily my favorite part about this job is traveling to unfamiliar places and talking to strangers. Even if the interview doesn't go well, and some of them haven't, trust me. As it turns out, cops don't love it when you ask them a thousand questions about why they couldn't solve a murder. But one thing I've learned over the years is if the person you're talking to walks out of their house to greet you rather than waiting for you to come to the door, it means the interview is going to go just fine. And that's how we were greeted by Michael Wynn. My name is Michael Wynn, and I guess these days I'm the unofficial historian for Central Louisiana. After a long career in law enforcement, Michael spends most of his free time researching local history.
我这份工作最喜欢的部分无疑是去到不熟悉的地方并和陌生人交谈。即使采访进展不顺——相信我，有些确实不顺。事实证明，当你问警察成千上万个关于他们为什么破不了谋杀案的问题时，他们并不太高兴。但我多年来学到的一件事是，如果你交谈的人走出家门来迎接你，而不是等你在门口敲门，这意味着采访会非常顺利。这就是迈克尔·温迎接我们的方式。我叫迈克尔·温，我想如今我是中路易斯安那州的非官方历史学家。在经历了漫长的执法生涯后，迈克尔把大部分空闲时间都花在了研究地方历史上。
But his passion for recording history didn't start with Central Louisiana. As a teenager, Michael developed an obsession with interviewing older relatives. I love when I hear somebody says, I have a boring family history. I don't know. I don't know. They didn't do anything. I say it's because you don't know anything about your history. Everybody has a story. No matter what you think, everybody has a story if you're willing to listen to him. And I came up with what I felt with perfect history books on my family, and I'm very, very proud of him. But then after I published him, I realized what's next. So Michael decided to just zoom out a tad.
但他对记录历史的热情并不是从中路易斯安那州开始的。十几岁时，迈克尔对采访年长的亲戚产生了一种痴迷。我喜欢听到有人说，我的家族史很无聊。我不知道。我不知道。他们什么都没做。我说那是因为你对自己的历史一无所知。每个人都有故事。不管你怎么想，只要你愿意倾听，每个人都有故事。我想出了我所认为的关于我家族的完美历史书，我对此感到非常非常自豪。但在我出版它们之后，我意识到接下来该做什么。所以迈克尔决定把镜头稍微拉远一点。
He'd recorded his family history. Now, how about his community's history? He was under the impression at the time that the history of Central Louisiana was pretty well written. But still, he decided to take a look. And I remember reading in the Chamber of Commerce magazine, they had this did you know section. And one of the things in the did you know section was John Wesley Hardin, the West's greatest criminal, was housed in the Alexandria City jail. Well, what was he in jail for?
他已经记录了他的家族史。现在，他的社区历史又如何呢？他当时有个印象，认为中路易斯安那州的历史已经被写得相当不错了。不过，他还是决定看一看。我记得在商会杂志上读到过，他们有一个“你可知”栏目。“你可知”栏目里的其中一件事是，西部最大的罪犯约翰·韦斯利·哈丁曾被关押在亚历山大市监狱里。嗯，他因为什么入狱的？
So Michael did a little research. He called a John Wesley Hardin biographer out in California, who had written several books on the guy, and asked him if he knew why Hardin was arrested in Alexandria, Louisiana. He starts laughing at me. He was never in that Louisiana. I know almost his day-to-day movement. He was never in Louisiana.
于是迈克尔做了一点研究。他打电话给加州的一位约翰·韦斯利·哈丁传记作家，那人写过几本关于此人的书，并问他是否知道哈丁为什么在路易斯安那州亚历山大被捕。他开始哈哈大笑。他从来没有去过那个路易斯安那。我几乎了解他每一天的行踪。他从来没有去过路易斯安那。
What the hell do y'all have over there? And I realize the first story I hit that I wanted to write more about, I'm debunking. And so Michael's first encounter with Central Louisiana history sort of recalibrated his mission. He wasn't really writing Central Louisiana history. He was correcting it. So Michael kept digging in the local archives, looking for other peculiar stories. And I see this mention in 1906 an interview with a black man.
你们那边到底有什么鬼东西？我意识到我遇到的第一个我想写得更多的故事，其实是在辟谣。所以迈克尔与中路易斯安那州历史的第一次接触某种程度上重构了他的使命。他其实不是在写中路易斯安那州的历史。他是在纠正它。因此，迈克尔继续在地方档案馆里深挖，寻找其他奇怪的故事。我看到1906年有一篇提到对一个黑人采访的报道。
Now, let me back up a little bit. African Americans have always been treated poorly. We're particularly treated poorly back then. and were particularly treated poorly in central Louisiana. I have basically never seen an interview before 1920s with an African-American in a newspaper in central Louisiana. It's all white. You'd never know there was a black person in Pineville.
现在，让我退回一点来讲。非裔美国人一直受到劣待。我们在当时尤其受到劣待。在中路易斯安那州尤其受到劣待。我基本上从来没见过1920年代之前中路易斯安那州的报纸上有对非裔美国人的采访。全都是白人。你绝不会知道派恩维尔还有一个黑人。
This 1906 article was published in the Alexandria Town Talk. It was about a Pineville resident named Charles Frederick Page. Michael, a man who spent years interviewing people in Central Louisiana, had never heard of him. The headline reads, Pineville colored man has invented an airship. It goes on to say that Charles Page made an application for a patent and that it was granted to him by the federal government in April of 1906.
这篇1906年的文章发表在《亚历山大镇论坛报》上。讲的是一个名叫查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇的派恩维尔居民。迈克尔，一个花多年时间采访中路易斯安那州人的人，以前从未听说过他。头条新闻写道：“派恩维尔有色人种发明了一艘飞艇。”文章接着说，查尔斯·佩奇提出了专利申请，并于1906年4月获得联邦政府批准。
As Michael read the article, he wondered, how have I never heard of this? I searched my library through history books and everything and other sources, references, vertical files. Not a damn word on this man. So Michael began digging through records. piecing together a biography of Charles Frederick Page and trying to figure out what the deal was with this so-called airship.
当迈克尔读这篇文章时，他想，我怎么从来没听说过这个？我在我的图书馆里翻遍了历史书、各种资料、参考文献、垂直档案。关于这个人，一个字也没有。于是迈克尔开始查阅记录。拼凑出查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇的传记，并试图弄清楚这艘所谓的飞艇是怎么回事。
Charles Page was, in fact, born into slavery. He grew up in Pineville and received no formal education. But he was able to teach himself to read and write and decipher, as they used to say in the old day, which was arithmetic. Michael then tracked down various other details, including a 1974 interview with Charles Page's daughter, Eva Page. And at some point in the 1890s, according to his daughter, Eva, he was looking up in a mosquito hawk one day and said, according to her, if a mosquito hawk can fly,
查尔斯·佩奇实际上出生于奴隶制家庭。他在派恩维尔长大，没有接受过正规教育。但他能够自学读写，并破译（就像老一辈人常说的那样）算术。迈克尔随后追踪了各种其他细节，包括1974年对查尔斯·佩奇的女儿伊娃·佩奇的采访。根据他女儿伊娃的说法，在1890年代的某个时候，他有一天抬头看着一只蚊鹰，据她说，他说，如果蚊鹰能飞，
I can fly. Now, here is a poor man working a farm with a gigantic family in a very depressive community and he decides he wants to build himself an airship, something that did not exist. and here is this man saying, I'm going to do it. Ava Page also had the original patent papers, including the approved design for the airship, which have since been scanned and shared with us. The design drawings for this airship are truly a magical sight. It looks like something out of the imaginarium of Dr. Parnassus or Peter Pan or something.
我也能飞。现在，这是一个在极其压抑的社区里靠耕种养活庞大家庭的穷苦男人，他决定要给自己造一艘飞艇——一种并不存在的东西。而这个男人却说：“我要把它造出来。”伊娃·佩奇还保留着原始的专利文件，包括飞艇获批的设计图，这些文件后来已被扫描并分享给我们。这艘飞艇的设计图简直是一个神奇的景象。它看起来像是帕纳苏斯博士的幻想剧场、彼得潘或类似作品中的东西。
The whole of the ship is made out of wire, with an oiled canvas stretched over the wire like a drum. Then bursting out of the ship are two enormous, balloons or gas bags, which are powered by an intricate system of pumps, valves, and pistons. On the back of the ship is a propeller and a rudder. I'm not sure how to put this, but even on the page, this black and white two-dimensional drawing of an airship appears to be flying. The text on the patent says that Charles F. Page of Pineville, Louisiana has, quote, invented certain new and useful improvements to airships, and then proceeds with a long, meticulously detailed description
整艘飞船由铁丝制成，像鼓一样将上油的帆布拉伸在铁丝上。然后从飞船中爆发出两个巨大的气球或气囊，由一套复杂的泵、阀门和活塞系统提供动力。飞船后面是一个螺旋桨和一个方向舵。我不知道该怎么表达，但即使在纸面上，这幅黑白二维的飞船图纸也显得仿佛在飞翔。专利文本上说，路易斯安那州派恩维尔的查尔斯·F·佩奇，引述，“对飞艇做出了一些新的、有用的改进发明”，然后是一段长篇的、极其详尽的描述
of how the airship works. And in the interview, Ava Page says the same thing we heard from Joseph Page, that Charles Page built a full-sized airship, and he entered the 1904 Louisiana Purchase Exposition in St. Louis, which offered at least $100,000 in prizes for aviation. So he shipped his airship on a freight train, and for reasons that were never known, the airship did not make it. And this is where the mystery occurs, and we have to rely on family stories. The ship never made it there. And the only thing I can think is the massive prejudice of the time, somebody stole it and destroyed it. And that's what the family says.
关于飞艇是如何运作的。在采访中，伊娃·佩奇说出了我们从约瑟夫·佩奇那里听到的相同事情，即查尔斯·佩奇建造了一艘全尺寸的飞艇，并参加了在圣路易斯举行的1904年路易斯安那购地博览会，该博览会为航空提供至少10万美元的奖金。于是他把飞船装上了货运列车，由于永远不为人知的原因，飞船没能到达。这就是谜团发生的地方，我们不得不依赖家族故事。飞船根本没到那儿。我能想到的唯一一件事就是当时大规模的偏见，有人把它偷走并毁掉了。家族就是这么说的。
I see no other reasonable alternative. The train didn't wreck along the way. And I think because of this disaster, the loss of his airplane, he had a major investment in this. I think he lost heart in it and he gave up on it. I wanted to know how things might have gone. if Charles Page and his airship had arrived at the Louisiana Purchase Exposition. So I did some research, and this thing was a spectacle.
我看不到其他合理的替代方案。火车在路上没有出轨。我认为正是因为这场灾难、他的飞机的丢失，他在上面投入了巨资。我想他对此灰心丧气，并放弃了它。我想知道，如果查尔斯·佩奇和他的飞艇按时抵达路易斯安那购地博览会，事情会怎么发展。所以我做了一些研究，这东西真是一场奇观。
So the main airship competition was actually a race. The favorite to win the race was a fabulously wealthy Brazilian man named Alberto Santos Dumont, aka the Wizard of the Air. It's unclear to me if that nickname was given to Santos Dumont or if he gave it to himself. In any case, Santos Dumont had already flaunted his airship at an exhibition in Paris. He arrived in St. Louis to a crush of reporters and fans. fans clamoring to see the man who had reportedly flown. You're probably picturing a small man in a suit with a mustache and a bowler hat, and that's exactly right. That's exactly what he looks like.
主要的飞艇比赛其实是一场竞速赛。夺冠呼声最高的是一位极其富有的巴西人，名叫阿尔贝托·桑托斯·杜蒙，又名“空中奇才”。我不太清楚这个绰号是别人给桑托斯·杜蒙的，还是他自己取的。无论如何，桑托斯·杜蒙已经在巴黎的一个展览上炫耀过他的飞艇。他抵达圣路易斯时，蜂拥而至的记者和粉丝们
Leaning into his penchant for drama and flair, Sontes Dumont told the St. Louis dispatch, if the world's fair accomplishes nothing more for science than to stimulate the conquest of air by man, it will have served a noble purpose. Dumont's main competition was a man from California, also wealthy, named Tom Baldwin, who had designed an airship he called the Arrow. It's worth mentioning that none of these airships look like Charles Page's airship. They have oblong cigar-shaped balloons with skimpy metal scaffolding that converge on a tiny seat for the pilot beneath the balloon, and somewhere in there you'll find a propeller and a rudder. It's more of a guidable blimp than an airship.
挤破头想见这位据说已经飞过的人。你脑海中浮现的可能是一个穿着西服、留着小胡子、戴着圆顶礼帽的小个子男人，完全没错了。他看起来就是那样。倾向于戏剧性和引人注目，桑托斯·杜蒙对《圣路易斯快报》说，如果世博会对科学没有别的贡献，只是激发了人类对天空的征服，那么它就已经达到了崇高的目的。杜蒙的主要竞争对手是一个来自加利福尼亚的富人，名叫汤姆·鲍德温，他设计了一艘名为“箭”号的飞艇。值得一提的是，这些飞艇看起来都不像查尔斯·佩奇的飞艇。它们拥有长圆形雪茄状的气球，带有单薄的金属脚手架，在气球下方的微小飞行员座椅处汇聚，某个地方你会找到一个螺旋桨和一个方向舵。与其说是飞艇，不如说它更像是一个可操控的飞船。
And the competition itself was very eventful. After testing his airship, Tom Baldwin, the Californian, was attempting to tie down the vessel when the crew lost control of the ropes. The airship took flight without a pilot. it was discovered days later in a field miles away. But despite this one blunder, Baldwin's airship was making very impressive test runs around the exposition's grounds. Baldwin appeared to be a real contender. And that's when scandal struck. In the middle of the night, leading up to the much-anticipated airship race,
而且竞赛本身也是 精彩纷呈。来自加州的托马斯·鲍德温在测试了他的飞艇后，正试图把飞艇系劳，这时船员却抓不住缆绳了。飞艇在没有驾驶员的情况下飞走了。几天后，人们在数英里外的一块田野里发现了它。但尽管有这次失误，鲍德温的飞艇在博览会场地周围的试飞表现依然非常惊艳。鲍德温看起来是一个真正的夺冠热门。就在这时，丑闻爆发了。在备受期待的飞艇比赛前夜的半夜里，
someone had gone into Alberto Santos Dumont's hangar and slashed his balloons with a knife. At first, the detective assigned to the case suspected it was someone hired by a competitor. but the hangar was heavily guarded. The detective ultimately deduced that nobody could have slashed the balloons but Santos Dumont himself. But why? Because Santos Dumont feared losing the competition and couldn't tolerate the embarrassment. Santos Dumont was outraged by the accusation. He left in a huff, taking his torn-up balloons back to Paris for repair,
有人潜入阿尔贝托·桑托斯-杜蒙的机库，用刀划破了他的气球。起初，负责此案的侦探怀疑是竞争对手雇人干的。但机库防守森严。侦探最终推断，除了桑托斯-杜蒙本人，没人能划破这些气球。但为什么呢？因为桑托斯-杜蒙害怕输掉比赛，无法忍受这种难堪。桑托斯-杜蒙对这种指控感到愤怒。他气冲冲地离开了，把划破的气球带回巴黎修理，
vowing to return to St. Louis to prove his aeronautical prowess. When the airship race finally took place in December of 1904, Santos Dumont had not returned. turned. And of the remaining contestants, nobody was able to complete the course. The $100,000 prize was left on the table. But just take a second to imagine how surprised these well-heeled, swash-buckling pioneers of the sky would have been by the arrival of Charles Frederick Page, a black man with no formal education, very little money, and an airship that, at my personal opinion, is far more elegant than anything else on display. Would Charles Page of Pineville, Louisiana, have beaten
并誓言要回到圣路易斯来证明他的航空才能。当飞艇比赛终于在1904年12月举行时，桑托斯-杜蒙并没有回来。在剩下的参赛者中，没有人能够完成全程。那10万美元的奖金无人认领。但大家不妨花几秒钟想象一下，当查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇——一个没有受过正规教育、几乎没什么钱、而且拥有一艘在我看来比展出的任何东西都优雅得多的飞艇的黑人——出现时，这些身家丰厚、敢作敢当的天空先驱们会有多么惊讶。路易斯安那州派恩维尔的查尔斯·佩奇会击败
the likes of Captain Thomas Baldwin or another contestant named Count Henry Dela Vaux? We'll never know. Charles Page never made it to St. Louis, and neither did his airship. However, on April 10, 1906, two years after the winterless Louisiana Purchase exposition, Page's airship patent was formally approved by the United States government. Now, what's fascinating is the timing. That was the 1904 World's Fair. It took three years for his patent to go through. It also took the Wright brothers three years for their patent to go through.
托马斯·鲍德温船长或另一位名叫亨利·德拉沃克斯伯爵的参赛者吗？我们永远不会知道了。查尔斯·佩奇从来没有去过圣路易斯，他的飞艇也没有。然而，在1906年4月10日，即没有冬天的路易斯安那购地博览会结束两年后，佩奇的飞艇专利正式得到了美国政府的批准。现在，最奇妙的是它的时间。那是1904年的世界博览会。他的专利花了三年时间才批下来。莱特兄弟的专利也花了三年时间才批下来。
Charles Frederick Page's patent for his airship. His controllable vehicle for the sky beats the Wright brothers by one month in being issued. He gets a patent one month before the Wright brothers. Oh my God. Now, these are different devices. One is an airship and the other is an airplane. One heavier than air, one lighter than air. But still, the fact that Charles Page got his patent for a flying vessel
查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇的飞艇专利。他那辆可操控的天空载具比莱特兄弟早一个月获得批准。他比莱特兄弟早一个月拿到专利。我的天哪。现在，这些是不同的装置。一个是飞艇，另一个是飞机。一个是重于空气的，一个是轻于空气的。但尽管如此，查尔斯·佩奇能拿到飞行器的专利
before the vaunted Wright brothers is pretty remarkable. We'll probably never be able to prove that Charles Page built and flew his airship. And we'll probably never find out why it didn't make it to St. Louis. And maybe most mysterious of all, we may never know why Charles Page stopped pursuing his airship. Because even if there wasn't a physical ship, people were very interested in his patent. Michael Wynn was able to recover three pieces of original correspondence regarding Charles Page. Less than three weeks after Page's patent was approved, he received a letter from a businessman in Pennsylvania named C.G. Crispin, asking if the patent was for sale. Then a couple weeks later, C.G. Crispin wrote another letter, and this time he had a lot more to say.
比大名鼎鼎的莱特兄弟还要早，这真是相当了不起。我们可能永远无法证明查尔斯·佩奇建造并驾驶过他的飞艇。我们也可能永远无法查明它为什么没能去成圣路易斯。也许最神秘的是，我们可能永远不会知道查尔斯·佩奇为什么停止追求他的飞艇。因为即使没有实体飞艇，人们对他的专利也非常感兴趣。迈克尔·温成功找回了三封关于查尔斯·佩奇的原始信件。在佩奇的专利获批不到三周后，他收到了一位来自宾夕法尼亚州的商人C.G.克里斯平的信，询问该专利是否出售。然后又过了几周，C.G.克里斯平写了另一封信，这一次他有更多的话要说。
Crispin writes, quote, we have investigated your patent very thoroughly. And our judgment is it ought to sell for $30,000. This airship easily excels anything also in its line that is on the market today. And the third piece of correspondence was between Page and someone else. All we have for that third person is an envelope with a return address. Arthur's Patent Exhibition, 209 State Street, Chicago, Illinois. On the back of the envelope is a handwritten note that says, received from A. Arthur, September 24, 1907.
克里斯平写道，引述：我们已经非常彻底地研究了您的专利。我们的判断是，它应该能卖到3万美元。这艘飞艇远远胜过目前市场上同类产品中的任何东西。第三封信是佩奇和另外一个人之间的。我们关于那个第三个人的全部线索只有一个写有回信地址的信封：芝加哥伊利诺伊州州街209号亚瑟专利展览馆。信封背面有一张手写便条，上面写着：于1907年9月24日收到自A.亚瑟。
We don't know what became of those dealings between Charles Page, C.G. Crispin, and A. Arthur. All we have are those three pieces of correspondence, one of them stating that the patent for Page's airship was worth an estimated 30 grand. About a million dollars in today's money. I have zero information why it never happened. I believe it was an honest offer, but we have zero information. The story of Charles Page's airship certainly has its fair share of unanswered questions. But despite all that, Michael thought that what was known about Charles Page's achievements was certainly worth sharing. So he started writing articles and appearing on any local news media that would have him. I'm on television a lot here and radio and everything.
我们不知道查尔斯·佩奇、C.G.克里斯平和A.亚瑟之间的这些交易后来怎么样了。我们所拥有的只有那三封信，其中一封指出佩奇的飞艇专利估计价值3万美元。相当于今天的约一百万美元。我完全不知道为什么它最终没有下文。我相信这是一个真诚的报价，但我们没有任何信息。查尔斯·佩奇飞艇的故事肯定有很多未解之谜。但尽管如此，迈克尔认为，关于查尔斯·佩奇成就的已知信息绝对值得分享。于是他开始写文章，并出现在任何愿意邀请他的本地新闻媒体上。我经常上这里的电视、广播和各种节目。
And I was talking about Page and I get a call from Joe. And he said, I'm his grandson. I said, I hope you're happy with everything I'm doing. He says, I'm ecstatic with everything you're doing. I've tried to fight this when I was young trying to get the word out. and people just, it's either one of two things. They don't believe you or they don't want to believe you. But there was a historian slash inventor on the East Coast who did believe Joseph and Michael.
当时我正在谈论佩奇，然后我接到了乔的电话。他说，我是他的孙子。我说，我希望你对我的所作所为感到满意。他说，我对你做的一切欣喜若狂。我年轻时曾试图为此抗争，试图把消息传出去。而人们要么是这样，要么是那样。他们要么不相信你，要么不想相信你。但在东海岸有一位历史学家兼发明家确实相信约瑟夫和迈克尔。
And furthermore, he believed that if Charles Frederick Page's airship can disappear, then it can reappear. In 2016, Time Magazine published a special issue featuring the 100 most important inventors of all time. A man named James Howard was checking out at the growth. grocery store when he noticed the issue on the magazine rack. And on the front cover of this special edition, you saw the likely heroes. You saw the Edisons, right? You saw the Fords, you know, you saw the Teslas and the Alexander Graham Bells, and you even saw present-day heroes like Steve Jobs.
此外，他认为如果查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇的飞艇可以消失，那么它就可以再次出现。2016年，《时代》杂志出版了一期特刊，评选出有史以来最重要的100位发明家。一个名叫詹姆斯·霍华德的人在杂货店结账时，注意到了杂志架上的这期特刊。在这本特刊的封面显眼处，你看到了那些可能称得上英雄的人物。你看到了爱迪生，对吧？你看到了福特，你知道的，你看到了特斯拉和亚历山大·格雷厄姆·贝尔，你甚至看到了像史蒂夫·乔布斯这样的当代英雄。
James was not looking through this magazine as a casual reader. For 35 years, he has taught design and design history. He's an inventor himself with over 35 patents. To him, the Time Magazine list presented a great opportunity to honor inventors who, in the past, had not gotten their due because of racial prejudice. Now, Lloyd, I'm okay with not necessarily seeing a black face on the cover. I open up this magazine and I see not a single black face. Finally, James made it to the last page.
詹姆斯翻阅这本杂志并不是作为一名随意的读者。35年来，他一直教授设计和设计史。他本人也是一位拥有35项以上专利的发明家。对他来说，《时代》杂志的这份名单提供了一个绝佳的机会，来表彰那些过去由于种族偏见而没有得到应有评价的发明家。劳埃德，我其实并不介意封面上不一定非得看到一张黑人面孔。我翻开这本杂志，却发现连一张黑人面孔都没有。最后，詹姆斯终于翻到了最后一页。
And on the last page, there is one tiny thumbnail image of a black inventor who, upon casual observation, could pass as white. And James felt he had two options. He could be angry and hope that the next time around lists such as these would include black inventors, or he could take action. He chose the latter and got to work on developing the country's first Black Inventors Hall of Fame. He and a team of other experts would make their own list. In our conversation, James gave me an abridged history of Black Inventors in America.
而在最后一页上，只有一个黑人发明家的微小缩略图，如果不仔细观察，他可能会被当成白人。詹姆斯觉得他有两个选择。他可以感到愤怒，并希望下一次这样的名单能包括黑人发明家，或者他可以采取行动。他选择了后者，并着手建立该国第一个黑人发明家名人堂。他和由其他专家组成的团队将制定他们自己的名单。在我们的交谈中，詹姆斯给我简述了美国黑人发明家的历史。
And it was clear to me that I had not been taught this history before. Time Magazine is not the only guilty party in omitting or overlooking black inventors. Their accomplishments have been overlooked for centuries. Take this example. One of the first major contributions by a black innovator in the United States can be traced back to a man named Onesimus. Onesimus lived in Boston during the 1721 smallpox epidemic, a disease which killed 30% of its victims. And as the disease decimated Boston, Onesimus recommended a novel procedure.
我很清楚，在此之前我没有学过这段历史。《时代》杂志并不是唯一一个遗漏或忽视黑人发明家的罪魁祸首。他们的成就几个世纪以来一直被忽视。举个例子。美国黑人创新者的最早重大贡献之一可以追溯到一个叫奥内西姆斯的人。奥内西姆斯生活在1721年波士顿天花流行期间，这种疾病夺去了30%患者的生命。当这种疾病蹂躏波士顿的时候，奥内西姆斯推荐了一种新颖的手术。
Procedure entailed rubbing pus from a smallpox wound into an open wound on the arm of an uninfected person. This provided a way to introduce antibodies, and in one key study, the fatality rate dropped from 1 in 7 to 1 in 40. And he went on to save the town of Boston from the ravages of smallpox with his introduction of the inoculation procedure that would go on to eventually become the world's first patented vaccine. he did not receive credit for. In this pattern of developing an innovation and receiving no credit, essentially defines the experience of black inventors in America. By 2023, James was deep into the planning for the Black Inventors Hall of Fame when he received an email from a board member.
这个程序包括将天花伤口的脓液擦到一个未感染的人手臂上的开放性伤口里。这提供了一种引入抗体的方法，在一项关键研究中，致死率从七分之一下降到四十分之一。他通过引入接种程序，最终成为了世界上第一个获得专利的疫苗，从而拯救了波士顿镇免受天花的蹂躏。但他没有得到应有的赞誉。这种发展创新却得不到赞誉的模式，基本上定义了美国黑人发明家的经历。到了2023年，詹姆斯正深入筹划黑人发明家名人堂时，他收到了一位董事会成员发来的电子邮件。
One of my board members sends me a link on Charles Frederick page. It has a little video captioning everything. And that was my first time ever hearing and learning about Charles Frederick. page. And the link that he sent me included Michael Wynn. I was so moved by it that I got in touch with Michael Wynn as soon as I got back to the office. Michael Wynne was thrilled. He shared all of his research with James, who spent weeks absorbing the story. The man who was born into slavery, who became a self-taught engineer, who invented and reportedly built an airship, sending it off to the Great Louisiana Purch's exposition of 1904, only to have it mysteriously disappear.
我的一位董事会成员给我发了一个关于查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇的网页链接。上面有一个小视频，概括了一切。那是我有生以来第一次听到并了解到查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇。他发给我的链接里还包含了迈克尔·韦恩。我对此深受触动，一回到办公室就立刻联系了迈克尔·韦恩。迈克尔·韦恩兴奋不已。他与詹姆斯分享了他所有的研究成果，詹姆斯花了好几个星期来消化这个故事。这个生于奴隶制、成为自学成才的工程师的人，发明并据说建造了一艘飞艇，将其送往1904年路易斯安那购地博览会，却让它神秘地消失了。
When we learned that Charles Frederick Page, airship had disappeared, and it never arrived at its destination, within that, you have a lot of mystery, right, as to, okay, well, what happened to it? You know, where did it go? Well, we don't have to be rocket scientists to sort of surmise where it went. It was purposely sequestered. It was purposely held back. There was no way that the powers that be, particularly in that particular region, of the United States at the time,
当我们得知查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇的飞艇消失了，而且从未到达目的地时，其中就包含了很多谜团，对吧？比如，到底发生了什么？你知道，它去哪儿了？好吧，我们不需要成为火箭科学家就能大致猜测它去了哪里。它是被故意隔离的。它是被故意压制的。当时的当权者，尤其是美国特定的那个地区，绝不可能……
was going to take a chance on the acknowledgement of this black man who has the audacity to be building a freaking airship at the same time, Orville Wright and Wilbur Wright were building their flying machine, had the audacity to ship it off. He had hoped to win that prize. And you're talking about a dream deferred. You can't get any more deferred than that.
会去冒险承认这个黑人，他居然敢在奥维尔·莱特和威尔伯·莱特制造飞行器的同时，建造一艘该死的飞艇，并且还大着胆子把它运送出去。他曾希望赢得那个奖项。这就是所谓的被延迟的梦想。再也没有比这更彻底的延迟了。
that has become the storyline that sort of encapsulates dozens upon dozens and hundreds upon hundreds of black inventors that came before him as well as those that have come since him. So I want to go back to that Time magazine issue, the one that motivated James to help enshrine the accomplishments of black inventors. The editor talks about what makes a great American inventor. It's quote, to invent and commercially succeed in shaping the world's first mass society, as Steve Jobs puts it, to put a dent in the universe. To commercially succeed. That phrase brings me back to those letters that Michael Wynn recovered. The correspondence between Charles Frederick Page and two men who were interested in shopping as patent.
这已经成为了一个故事情节，某种程度上概括了在他之前以及在他之后出现的一代又一代的黑人发明家。所以我想回到那一期的《时代》杂志，正是那期杂志激励了詹姆斯去帮助铭记黑人发明家的成就。编辑谈到了是什么造就了一位伟大的美国发明家。引用他的话说，就是在打造世界上第一个大众社会的进程中进行发明并获得商业成功，正如史蒂夫·乔布斯所说，要在宇宙中留下印记。获得商业成功。这句话让我想起了迈克尔·韦恩找回的那些信件。查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇与两个对购买他的专利感兴趣的人之间的通信。
C.G. Crispin from Pennsylvania and A. Arthur from Chicago. These letters represent Charles Page's attempts to commercially succeed with his ideas. But neither panned out, and Charles Page stopped trying. Why? I did a deep dive on both of these men to see if I could find anything relevant with respect to Page or other inventions they might have been selling. Who were these guys? What were they up to? Let's start with the first one, CG Crispin. Crispin was a very well-respected businessman and inventor out of Berwick, Pennsylvania. He was a Cornell graduate, the president of Berwick's first National Bank. He invented a water valve that was used across multiple industries, a very well-respected guy. It's possible that Charles Page granted Crispin permission to exhibit his patent, and nobody
来自宾夕法尼亚州的C.G.克里斯平（C.G. Crispin）和来自芝加哥的A.亚瑟（A. Arthur）。这些信件代表了查尔斯·佩奇试图让自己的创意获得商业成功的尝试。但两项尝试都失败了，查尔斯·佩奇也放弃了。为什么？我深入研究了这两个人，想看看是否能找到任何与佩奇或他们可能一直在出售的其他发明相关的有价值线索。这些家伙是谁？他们在搞什么鬼？让我们从第一个开始，CG·克里斯平。克里斯平是宾夕法尼亚州贝里克（Berwick）一位备受尊敬的商人和发明家。他是康奈尔大学的毕业生，也是贝里克第一国民银行的行长。他发明了一种被多个行业广泛使用的水阀，是一个非常受人尊敬的人。有可能查尔斯·佩奇授予了克里斯平展示他专利的许可，而没有人……
bought it. Or maybe for some reason, Page didn't send it in. We don't know. The more mysterious character, though, was A. Arthur. All we have is that envelope with a return address, and on the back of the envelope, there's a handwritten note that reads, received from A. Arthur on September 25th, 1907. It took me a long time to find anything about A. Arthur. But after a while, I was able to figure out that this guy's full name was Adam Arthur. Adam Arthur specialized in hosting and promoting patent exhibitions. But in early 1907, the building housing his exhibition burned to the ground, pushing Arthur to the brink of financial ruin.
买下它。或者出于某种原因，佩奇没有把它寄出去。我们不得而知。不过，更神秘的人物是A.亚瑟。我们所有的只有一个带有回信地址的信封，信封背面有一张手写便条，上面写着：“于1907年9月25日收到来自A.亚瑟的信。”我花了很长时间才找到关于A.亚瑟的任何信息。但过了一段时间，我终于弄清楚这个家伙的全名叫亚当·亚瑟（Adam Arthur）。亚当·亚瑟专门从事主办和推广专利展览。但在1907年初，存放他展览的建筑被一场大火烧为平地，将亚瑟逼到了破产的边缘。
And that's when I came across an article about Arthur from the Chicago Tribune. The article was dated October 25th, exactly one month after Charles, Page's correspondence with him. The headline reads, wife, creditors, and federal officials, hunt for Adam Arthur, denounced as a swindler. Apparently, Adam Arthur was writing to inventors saying, if you send me a deposit, I will exhibit your work, and if your work doesn't sell, I'll send your money back. Except he wasn't sending the money back. He was pocketing everything, including, I believe, Charles Page's deposit. I believe Charles Frederick Page was I think the evidence strongly suggests that he sent in the deposit expecting to have it returned,
就在那时，我偶然在《芝加哥论坛报》上看到了一篇关于亚瑟的文章。文章日期是10月25日，正好是查尔斯·佩奇与他通信一个月后。头条新闻写道：“妻子、债权人和联邦官员搜捕被斥为骗子的亚当·亚瑟。”显然，亚当·亚瑟当时写信给发明家们说：“如果你寄给我一笔押金，我就会展出你的作品，如果你的作品卖不出去，我会把钱退给你。”但他并没有退钱。他把所有钱都揣进了腰包，其中我相信也包括查尔斯·佩奇的押金。我相信查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇……我认为有强有力的证据表明，他寄出押金是期望能拿回来的……
but the money never came back. And as a timberman in Pineville, Louisiana, with a wife and 11 kids, Charles Page decided that dealing with untrustworthy strangers in far-flung cities was not something he could afford to do any longer. That's why Charles Page couldn't commercially succeed with his intellectual property. He was taken advantage of. As a poor black man in Louisiana, he had no means for recourse. Perhaps if Charles Page were not born into slavery and thrust into the nightmare of Jim Crow, he would have met the criteria for times 100 most important inventors. Charles Page's whole experience, the disappearance of his machine, the obstacles that prevented him from profiting from his invention,
但这笔钱再也没有退回来。作为路易斯安那州派恩维尔（Pineville）的一名伐木工人，有着妻子和11个孩子，查尔斯·佩奇决定，与远方城市里那些不值得信任的陌生人打交道，是他再也承担不起的事情。这就是为什么查尔斯·佩奇的知识产权无法获得商业成功的原因。他被利用了。作为一个路易斯安那州的贫穷黑人，他没有任何申诉的途径。也许如果查尔斯·佩奇不是生于奴隶制并被推入吉姆·克劳法的噩梦中，他本可以符合《时代》杂志评选的100位最重要的发明家的标准。查尔斯·佩奇的整个经历、他的机器的消失、阻碍他从发明中获利的重重障碍……
the lack of recognition for his scientific achievements. It all represented a highly emblematic story for the Black Inventors Hall of Fame. And as a result, James has decided to make Charles Frederick Page a centerpiece of the museum. You're going to be able to go in there and you're going to be able to learn of Charles Frederick Page's story. There's going to be a little theater in there where you can sit on a bench and see a six to eight minute recapturing of his story when he first learned that his airship had disappeared. But as James planned the Charles Page exhibit, he couldn't seem to take his eyes off those original patent designs, the beautifully drawn renderings of this magical flying ship. Yes, James is a historian, and yes, he is developing a museum. but he is also a working inventor, so he decided to do some experimenting.
以及对他科学成就缺乏认可。这一切都为黑人发明家名人堂提供了一个极具象征意义的故事。因此，詹姆斯决定将查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇作为博物馆的核心展品。你将能够走进那里，了解查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇的故事。里面会有一个小剧场，你可以在长椅上坐下来，观看一段6到8分钟的短片，重现他当年得知自己的飞艇消失时的情景。但正当詹姆斯规划查尔斯·佩奇展区时，他的目光似乎始终无法从那些最初的专利设计图上移开——那些精美绘制的魔法飞行船渲染图。是的，詹姆斯是一位历史学家，是的，他正在筹建一座博物馆。但他同时也是一位正在从事创作的发明家，因此他决定做一些实验。
I took a look at the patent drawings, and I challenged my model maker and say, listen, let's take these and let's extrapolate them into 3D renderings, 3D models. Then I say, I want to take it one step further. Let's extract these into built information modeling, akin to architecture drawings, right, where you can literally sort of like build the building before you physically build it. And I saw the credibility of his propulsion system and his guiding system and then the brilliance of the balloons and the tethers and the deck and everything. I say to myself, you know what? This has to be built, but not a model.
我查看了专利图纸，并向我的模型制作师提出挑战，我说：“听着，让我们把这些转化为3D渲染图、3D模型。”接着我说：“我想再往前一步。让我们将这些提取为建筑信息模型，类似于建筑图纸，对吧？在那里你可以字面意义上像在实体建造之前先建好这座建筑一样。”我看到了他的推进系统和导向系统的可靠性，以及气球、系绳、甲板等一切的精妙之处。我对自已说：“你知道吗？这个东西必须被建造出来，但不是做成模型。”
I told my board, I say, listen, we need to build a full-size replica. It was a bold idea and one which presented an obvious challenge. Who do you hire to build a 120-year-old. year old airship. Well, James happened to have a relationship with a London-based company that helped him with a replica of a P-51 fighter plane for a Tuskegee Airman exhibit. The company is called Spirit in the Sky, and they specialize in, quote, aerial filming solutions for feature films, music videos, TV productions, and commercials. You've actually probably seen their work in movies like Mission Impossible, Dead Reckoning, or the 007 movie, No Time to Die, or the Apple series, Masters of the Sky. These guys are the
我告诉我的董事会，我说：“听着，我们需要建造一个全尺寸的复制品。”这是一个很大胆的想法，也带来了一个显而易见的挑战：你该去哪里雇人来建造一个有120年历史的飞艇呢？好吧，詹姆斯碰巧与一家总部设在伦敦的公司有过合作，该公司曾为塔斯克基飞行员（Tuskegee Airman）展览帮他制作过一架P-51战斗机的复制品。这家公司名叫“天空之灵”（Spirit in the Sky），他们专门为故事片、音乐录影带、电视制作和广告提供所谓的“航空拍摄解决方案”。你实际上可能在电影中见过他们的作品，比如《碟中谍7：致命清算》、007电影《无暇赴死》，或者是苹果剧集《空战群英》。这些家伙绝对是……
real deal. So James showed the page renderings to his point of contact there. I'd like to show you these models that we've built in the computer and can you extrapolate this into an actual full-size item. Then I told them that I wanted to have it on display in my museum. He looked at all the drawings. He called me back and say, James, listen, man, why would you want to put it in your museum? He says, why don't you go ahead and let us make this baby fly? And I said, we can consider that. And now, to actually build the ship, James has partnered with an engineering group in Maine. At the time this episode was released, the ship was still under construction. But what seems clear to both James and all the engineers involved is that the airship can fly.
货真价实的专家。于是詹姆斯把佩奇的渲染图拿给他在那里的联络人看。“我想给你看看我们在电脑里建立的这些模型，你能把这个转化成一个实际的全尺寸物品吗？”然后我告诉他，我想把它放在我的博物馆里展出。他看了所有的图纸。他回电话给我说：“詹姆斯，听着，伙计，你为什么要把这东西放在博物馆里呢？为什么不直接让我们把这个宝贝飞起来呢？”我说：“我们可以考虑一下。”为了真正建造这艘飞艇，詹姆斯目前已经与缅因州的一个工程集团展开了合作。在该集播客发布之时，这艘飞艇仍在建造中。但对詹姆斯和所有参与的工程师来说，显而易见的是，这艘飞艇能够飞行。
So I asked James. You know, there's some speculation on whether Charles Frederick Page flew the original airship, whether or not he actually got it off the ground. Do you have an opinion on that? I do have an opinion. I'll be honest with you. I think that as a inventor, you have to understand. Your invention becomes one with you.
所以我问詹姆斯：“你知道，关于查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇是否驾驶过原版飞艇，他是否真的让它离地升空，存在一些猜测。你对此有什么看法吗？”我确实有看法。老实说，我认为作为一个发明家，你必须明白，你的发明已经与你融为一体。
You live it, you eat it, you breathe it, right? And I firmly believe, I firmly believe that Charles Frederick Page attempted to lift this airship off the ground and fly. And then you have to think about this. You go back and read the requirements of the Louisiana's World Fair Competition.
你靠它生活，靠它吃饭，靠它呼吸，对吧？我坚信，我坚信查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇曾试图让这艘飞艇离地升空并进行飞行。然后你必须考虑这一点。你回过头去阅读路易斯安那世博会竞赛的要求。
It's a requirement that whatever it is you present has to work. Why? Because at the World's Fair, it was the intention to showcase these,
其中有一项要求，即你展示的任何东西都必须能够运作。为什么？因为在世博会上，其意图是展示这些东西……
not on the ground, but in the air, right? So if you trace it all the way back to what the moment required, this man felt confident enough to measure up to that moment. He was just never given that opportunity. But about 120 years after it reportedly disappeared on its way to the Louisiana Purchase exposition,
不是在地面上，而是在空中，对吧？所以如果你一直追溯到当时那一刻的要求，这个杰出的人有足够的自信来应对那个时刻。只是他从来没有得到过那个机会。但在它据称在前往路易斯安那购地博览会的途中消失大约120年后……
Charles Page's airship will reappear. Though he will not be there to enjoy it, Page's work will be on display for the world to see. And if someone really did destroy Page's airship, that person will have ultimately failed to suppress this man's undeniable, innovative brilliance. In the beginning of this episode, I mentioned those specialty quarters released by the United States meant. The back of the North Carolina quarter shows the Wright brothers, as it should. The Wright brothers have a completely legitimate claim as leading pioneers in aviation. But they weren't the only pioneers in aviation. There were others who had to overcome more than
查尔斯·佩奇的飞艇将再次出现。尽管他将无法亲自享受这一切，但佩奇的作品将向全世界展出。如果真的有人摧毁了佩奇的飞艇，那么这个人最终也将无法压制这个男人无可否认的创新才华。在本集的开头，我提到了美国铸币局发行那些特别纪念币。北卡罗来纳州纪念币的背面刻有莱特兄弟，这是理所当然的。莱特兄弟作为航空业的领先先驱，拥有完全合法的地位。但他们并不是唯一的航空先驱。还有其他人，他们必须克服的远不止……
just the forces of gravity. Well, on the back of Louisiana specialty quarter, you will see two things, a map of the Louisiana purchase, the epic land deal that was commemorated by the exposition of 1904, and above that you'll see a bird. Though it was not intended this way, I hope those two images always remind you of a great American inventor named Charles Frederick Page. Thank you for listening to Family Lore. If you have stories you'd like to share about your family,
仅仅是重力。好吧，在路易斯安那州特别纪念币的背面，你会看到两样东西：一张路易斯安那购地案的地图——那是1904年世博会所纪念的伟大土地交易，在其上方你会看到一只鸟。虽然并非刻意为之，但我希望这两个意象能永远让你想起一位名叫查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇的伟大美国发明家。感谢收听《家族传说》（Family Lore）。如果你有关于你的家族的故事想要分享……
please email me at FamilyLorePod at gmail.com. That's FamilyLoreP-O-D at Gmail.com. Family lore is an Odyssey original podcast. It is written and narrated by me, Lloyd Lockridge, Our executive producers are Leah Reese Dennis and I. Our lead producer and sound editor is Zach Clark. Our story editors are Maddie Sprung Kaiser and Katie Mingle. Additional sound editing, mixing, and mastering by Chris Basil,
请发电子邮件至 FamilyLorePod@gmail.com。也就是 FamilyLoreP-O-D@gmail.com。《家族传说》是奥德赛（Audyssey）原创播客。它由我——劳埃德·洛克里奇（Lloyd Lockridge）撰写并旁白。我们的执行制片人是利亚·里德·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）和我。我们的首席制片人和声音编辑是扎克·克拉克（Zach Clark）。我们的故事编辑是麦迪·斯普朗·凯瑟（Maddie Sprung Kaiser）和凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）。另外的声音编辑、混音和母带制作由克里斯·巴塞尔（Chris Basil）完成，
and production support by Sean Cherry. Special thanks to Mora Curran, Josephina Francis, Kurt Courtney, Hillary Schuff, and Laura Berman. Thanks again for listening to Family Lore. And if you have time, we'd love for you to rate and review the show. Subscribe to Family lore. It is fantastic. Get it wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
制作支持由肖恩·切里（Sean Cherry）提供。特别感谢莫拉·柯兰（Mora Curran）、约瑟芬娜·弗朗西斯（Josephina Francis）、库尔特·考特尼（Kurt Courtney）、希拉里·舒夫（Hillary Schuff）和劳拉·伯曼（Laura Berman）。再次感谢收听《家族传说》。如果你有时间，我们希望你能为本节目评分和评论。订阅《家族传说》。这非常棒。无论你在哪里收听播客，都可以获取它。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。